So, rolling — movement around the longitudinal axis. Looks exactly like this, and it of course also happens in
calm flight, but also when entering a thermal: the wing can get knocked off its axis from the side
and start rolling around the longitudinal axis. The goal is, of course, to prevent that,
meaning we want to stabilise the wing and ourselves again. To help you picture the whole thing,
I quickly sketched this. So, we're at the start point and we draw
an imaginary line, and around this line — that's actually what you need to do each time you've
let the wing drift — bring it back with the brake, not so far that it leaves the line, but so it returns
back onto this imaginary line. But it'd be like flying zigzag
to this line — well, that'd be great. Now, important when rolling: body input first,
brake second. The body always comes first and the brake later. Also try not
to pull the brake too quickly — keep a certain dynamic in the brake. So I
wait with the brake, then on the brake input pull a bit more, down to the chest, and then release.
A certain dynamic — shift weight to the new side, wait, on the brake pull a bit more down to the
chest, and release again. That would be a dynamic brake input. Now when does the
change come — that's always the question many pilots and students struggle with. We begin with
rolling to the left. That means we steer the wing left so that the pilot swings out
to the right side, and now when the pilot is at the highest point, that's already when the change to
the new side comes. That means: lean your weight onto the right side, so that as much as possible you don't yet
have to work with the right brake. The wing then already starts moving onto the new side
and after the lowest dead point, pull the brake. Let me show it again quickly, so:
lean weight in, then pull brake down to the chest, pull dynamically, snap, up, and
steer to the new side. And now wait until we've swung through the bottom, then again
pull the brake on the other side, somewhat dynamically to the chest, and release again. Snap, wait,
wait, wait, wait, pull brake, pull dynamically, and snap, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, pull brake, pull dynamically — and exit, very simple, the same as we did with the last roll:
right, snap, hand up, you can stay sitting in the straps, leave both hands
up, wait until we've swung up, and now the wing comes back from behind to the front again,
both hands off the brakes completely, just wait until we've swung underneath and then
step slowly. Actually, from the explanation, it's very, very simple, but it needs good
timing — bank and body — how aggressively you can shift the body over quickly, and
when the brake comes. There too, in the beginning start slow — we'll work up to more with each
round, I'll say go a bit more, or a bit more powerfully. Often you also pull
the brake a bit too short, or one side more than the other. So at the start
it's really important: both sides evenly, both sides at the same time, and the
intensity of the brake also has to look the same on both sides. If we, for example,
go too high — let's say here we make the swing to the left a bit too high —
then the outer wingtip can collapse. If that happens, don't continue,
you absolutely have to stop, wait until the wing has stopped swinging, either with both brakes brought straight
to a stop, or wait through the normal exit until the wing comes from behind to the front and then
catch it with both brakes. But there I certainly won't let you continue. Good. For
the rolling manoeuvre, a defined flight axis is taken. By dosed, alternating
pulling and releasing of the left and right brake line, a rhythmic rocking around the
longitudinal axis is generated. Careful: braking too hard or wrong intervals can lead to dangerous flight states.
Once you have a steady roll, small brake impulses are enough to sustain the oscillations up to the
correct angle. To exit the manoeuvre, a single
impulse is skipped and then the final roll of the wing is caught with brake impulses followed by
dosed release of the brake lines.